this is drifting in both the real world
and in video games like need for speed
it takes our stack of confidence and
some serious skills to pull off
those are skills that I don't really
have at least not at the moment we're
here at Sonny Silverstone to enlist the
help of caterham who are going to try
and help me learn to be just a little
bit like ken Block one of the stars of
need for speed first of all my coach for
the day Jack explains what's actually
happening when you're drifting so the
idea of drifting is holding oversteer
that's where the back of the car steps
out and the front of the car has grip so
that's the sideways motion that you're
taking through the corner there's a few
things you can do to essentially
unbalance the car and that's what you're
doing you're trying to break traction so
you're trying to go against every
instinct you have on circuit you don't
want to be smooth you want to be pretty
aggressive to a point and then there's a
few things you can do such as you know
working the throttle obviously breaking
quite hard and turning quite positively
initially it's definitely on the fastest
way but it's the most entertaining way
and that's the key thing it is
entertainment and it's to some extent
and art form it's like playing a musical
instrument or painting something or you
know creating a video or whatever it is
it's it's it's not about going fast it's
not about ticking boxes because there is
no box to tick you know it's a bit of a
blank canvas you can do whatever you
like and it's not wrong it's whatever
you want it to be with that on board and
some expert tutelage it was time for me
to get in the car the object of the day
would be simple to at least once in the
day get a shot of me on camera pulling
off a decent-looking drift over a corner
that I've been set up for me in cones
before we could start to tackle that
though we started with some warm-up
exercises
so so far so good it started very slow
and then the cable point where it
started to come together right give her
a few more shots though because I think
there's more in it for me yeah this is
fun it's really really fun
the start didn't look so promising but
very slowly I started to get to grips
with the basics
right there you can see it's either not
as easy as it looks around just a [ __ ]
but either way that is so much fun that
is crazy fun the instruction jack has
been giving is excellent my ability to
put it into practice however leave
something to be desired the real neck is
not just knowing what to do it's
understanding how to react to the
feedback from the car understanding how
your inputs without steering be that
throttle compensate what's happening and
where you need to be I'm not looking in
the right place I'm not I'm either too
aggressive or not aggressive enough on
the throttle and my steering I'm doing
way too much of it so I'm absolutely
shattered right now but I'm on such an
adrenaline high that I don't care the
practicing has happened we're going to
set up and actually try and do this term
actually get this one corner to the look
anywhere near as competent as it should
do this is not a video game this has got
the actual the sights and the smells in
the sensation of not just speed but
Direction acceleration the smell of the
tires the pinging of stones off your
helmet I had to put all of that to one
side and focus on the job in hand Jack
quickly showed me exactly how I should
be looking exiting the corner and making
it look very easy in the process now it
was my turn to give it a go
it did not look good at the start but
slowly but surely the confidence was
building I couldn't quite string it
together though the Sun was getting low
and I was beginning to think I wasn't
going to get it done but then
Wow
tell me you got that on camera tell me
to go back yes it wasn't the most
dramatic of drifts but I've made it
round the corner at a slight angle the
whole way around and I couldn't be
happier what a day what a day that has
been so much fun and there right at the
end I think I just about got it there is
no way I could ever drift like Ken Block
not in real world but even in the car
set up for it like this but I came
pretty damn close to for that tiny
moment just getting a tiny glimpse of
what it's like to hold the car sideways
like that I need to do some more
drifting this is so damn cool so yes as
it turns out drifting is a lot harder
than it looks plus I burnt through an
entire tank of fuel and a brand new set
of tires in no time flat so you probably
would need deep pockets and a wide open
space not to mention someone else's car
if you ever wanted to get really really
good at it Plus despite all of that
practice you were still kind of not good
I mean you have to drive around a car
park not on public roads you had to wear
a silly hat helmet and when the Sun went
down you had to just go home and none of
that is going to be a problem in Need
for Speed you can get your sideways
thrill in a much easier way and can you
put your skills that you've just learned
to better use in need for speed or can I
just rock up having never tried this
before and do better than you I think we
should find out I mean starting with the
tire pressures we can just mess with all
of these set everything to the left
which is going to push it into the drift
setting so Starling with the tire
pressures then we're going to change the
steering as turn on breaking drift
assists definitely want the stability
switched off definitely no launch
control
you can even lock the differential so
it's just going to spin all the time I
think we probably got the slippiest car
we could possibly manage okay this was
kind of similar when I was out on the
track i set the car up to be the most
unstable so that makes it okay all right
let's go with that see this already
looks like a much more sexy environment
to try this out well I mean it's raining
to start with I feel like that's
probably going to help us out but
instead of staying out here on the
streets why don't we go and find
somewhere nice and bendy where hopefully
there's going to be a little less
traffic as well ok ok so my technique
for drifting has always been lots of
power and turning and I feel like that's
going to do me really well in this
corner hey yeah i think it's going to
take a little bit more subtle tea than
that try again ok oh oh that there we go
ok so lots of power totally viable
technique all right let's sir let's try
on these slightly bigger bends again
they're getting there lots of power lots
of power turn it turn it turn ok so
maybe it's it's not it's lacking a
little finesse oh I'll concede but but
in terms of getting the car sliding I
think we've rigged it up well seems to
not be able to sustain the corner with
my technique either but that just means
that it's dance technique which is kind
of cool you're not just jumping in and
the car is doing everything for you much
like in the real world we have
driving ourselves so you just think that
was less than ideal I died but beyond
that I think that was a good first try
but actually is a good point that you're
able to do that and jump straight back
on and keep going i'm pretty sure if
I've done something like go out on the
roads I would call it a day okay I feel
like maybe you need to show me how well
you can apply your skills to this game
right okay see this is applying the
techniques that I learned out there on
the track so upset the card ever breaks
get the back out it can be done okay
you're making this look a lot better
than I did and this is just with a full
day of burning tires who'd have thought
that would actually help in a video game
it's still not perfect though but the
great thing is is I can actually be a
lot more confident about getting it
wrong because even where I was out in
the car party was always a slight fear
that was going to kill someone yourself
someone else damage the car it was
really low on my list of priorities for
the day to kill someone so I wanted to
make sure that was avoided at all costs
so at the moment it would seem that a
day's worth of training makes me
marginally better prepared very
marginally better prepared and then you
are to actually take on but in any case
doing it on a wet dark mountain roads
does look that much better than in the
car park at Silverstone right so let's
actually try a mission around drifting
just to see
if we can actually use this to score
some in-game currency oh sure we can do
that all right this is worth points this
time here we go
oh come on oh you pushed me off fly yeah
i was doing well there
oh oh oh it's beautiful that was
beautiful you must be in the lead by now
I mean points wise obviously you're way
behind in the air that's right drifting
is not for speed drifting is for style
I've seen tokyo drift on hours hey I'm
gonna be your personal DK that sounds
really rude yes Oh what's there with
four times multiplier Oh car OH
threading the needle look you
successfully threaded a needle I
threaded a needle I am a new personal
best okay double the braking power
steer-in besafe sa birthday visit oh yes
nice who the stress levels are high see
that is the same between the game and
real life okay intensity does get your
heart pumping okay
we're getting the hang of this ya feelin
it I'm feeling this now I feel like I'm
I've got the drift I the drift drift I
is a is a zone it's a zen-like State
sounds like something you'd go to the
optometrist or yeah that's it that's it
ah feel like keeping the power on is the
hardest part yeah it's not all power all
the time its you have to feed the power
to get keep the back where you want it
now boy other way drift King coming
through oh I'm is there an ice cream
truck in the road there's people like
ice cream no one likes ice cream in the
mountains this generalization of core
Melton coat how did I do new personal
best that's the thing that means I beat
you it probably doesn't mean believe me
how did that work I think I was just
absorbing all of your skill and
technique oh yeah that was it yeah
there's a lot there to get into there's
a lot to sink your teeth into if you
want to try and get good at drifting you
can't just jump into this game and all
do everything for you you need to learn
how to do it properly definitely need a
bit of skill but on those bits where it
was going well it felt really good it
felt like it did when I was out on the
track when the back was going and I was
looking at the side and my little heart
was going and I've give me like a little
school boy and he had this big old grin
on your face and just the tiniest little
bit of drift although it looked more
spectacular there then it did in the
real world it still felt pretty good in
both did we go plus you get all the good
with none of the fear so it all actually
works out to a greater whole I do prefer
my enjoyment with the minimum amount of
death yes as most people do yeah if I
can eradicate death from my fun I've had
a good day what a great any well at
least I can say that without any real
world drifting experience it was
absolutely possible to become a student
of sideways though I will admit that
your technique of not using
all the time had quite a lot of Merit
yeah a lot of Merit dip on the brakes
power back on catch the slide and watch
it gently swing around and supposed to
kicking out like a mule yeah yours could
be stylish to drifting around the corner
elegantly a stylish but in the real
world that takes a lot of practice and
some fundamental skills space yeah yeah
and money yeah plus you'll need the
safety equipment think of the tires yeah
I all those things all those things but
at least in need for speed with a bit of
practice you can drift like a pro
you